Okay Steve, so as in the past, I'd introduce yourself.
My name is Steve Lawson, or in a conference room in Valley Library on 11th of November
2011.
So in our last session we talked quite a bit about the Mayo Clinic and Controversy, and
I don't know that we need to go over the details of that again, but I'm interested in knowing
a little bit more about the response from within the institute, especially if there is
a, there was ever a plan or an idea about developing a research program specifically in
response to what the Mayo Clinic had said.
I don't think that there was a plan to develop a research project in response to the Mayo
Clinic studies.
I think that Pauling and Cameron and anyone else who was sympathetic to their position
realized that the studies purportedly done to replicate Cameron's work were very flawed.
And as I mentioned last time, Cameron and Pauling were angry that the New England Journal
of Medicine, for instance, did not publish critical letters in a timely fashion.
And typically medical journals will publish critical letters while the original clinical
trial or study reported in that journal is still freshening people's minds.
And I think Pauling actually invoked his lawyer to contact Arnold Rellman of the New England
Journal of Medicine to find out what had happened to the letters that had been submitted.
Because the etiquette is that when you submit a publication or a letter to a journal for
consideration, for publication in that journal, you can't submit it elsewhere.
So this kind of stymied the ability of Cameron and Pauling to err their grievances about
the Mayo Clinic studies in print in a journal because they had already submitted really
cogent responses and Rellman seemed to be sitting on these for quite a long time.
I think finally they published something, but it was nearly a year after the original
study had been published.
Letters are read, but they certainly don't attract the kind of media interest that the
original study attracted.
So I think Cameron and Pauling felt that they needed to continue on showing that vitamin
C had value because they were both convinced by this time that vitamin C had value for many
cancer patients.
And Pauling was also becoming a little after the second Mayo Clinic trial.
He had heard from Abram Hauffer, the Canadian psychiatrist who had stimulated his interest
in B vitamins and schizophrenia back in the early 1960s or mid 1960s that Hauffer had
been treating cancer patients with high dose vitamin C given orally as well as an expanded
treatment regimen that included B vitamins, fatty acids, zinc and some other micronutrients.
And these cancer patients seem to be doing quite well.
So Pauling encouraged Hauffer to collect that data with the intent of analyzing it and
publishing it.
And they did that.
They published two papers in the Journal of Worth and Molecular Medicine on Hauffer's
observation.
So I think that this was not a response to the Mayo Clinic trials per se, but a continuation
of Pauling's deep interest in vitamin C and cancer.
And Hauffer had been, Hauffer is an MD-PhD as a psychiatrist by training in profession.
And you might wonder why he was treating cancer patients.
Well, it turns out that many cancer patients, especially when given a diagnosis, prognosis
of terminal cancer, developed psychological problems, depression, anxiety, whatnot.
And they were being referred to Hauffer by oncologists in Vancouver and Victoria in British
Columbia to treat these mental manifestations that accompanied the bad news about the
cancer diagnosis.
So Hauffer began treating these people for mental health issues and kind of serendipitously
observed that they were living much longer in many cases than they were expected to live
by their oncologists.
And he brought that observation to Pauling who encouraged him then to collect the data.
So Cameron and Pauling continued to be very interested in vitamin C and cancer.
And I think was a bit discouraged by the political implications of this whole embryo at the
Mayo Clinic.
And I think he became very frustrated and discouraged.
And his attention was also turned elsewhere.
He was very interested in fatty acids and cancer and had set up a project at the Institute
to study the effect of oral fats in animals in a tumor model.
And he was also becoming more and more interested in AIDS and the potential value of high dose
vitamin C in treating AIDS patients.
And as you know, he and Pauling worked on a book together that absorbed quite a lot of
Cameron's time and attention in those last years, which was never published.
Can you talk a little more about the fatty acids, Lyonid research?
Cameron, I believe, had known or knew of David Horabin's work in England.
And Horabin had written a book on omega-3 fatty acids.
He was a researcher and I believe he was also a clinician who was very interested in the
health, sort of the orthomolecular approach to health using fatty acids and other micronutrients.
But he was particularly interested in fatty acids and brain function.
And Horabin, when I saw him at some point in the 1980s or early 1990s, had reported on
a clinical trial, preliminary clinical trial done in England with, I believe, schizophrenia
who were given fatty acids supplementation and MRIs or computer tomography had been done
of their brains.
And they found that the ventricular spaces shrunk as a result of ingestion of these fatty
acids over a period of time, which also correlated with some symptomatic improvement.
So Horabin and Cameron, I think, too, were becoming very interested in the psychiatric
application of fatty acids.
And then from epidemiological studies and rodent studies, it's been known for a long
time that omega-6 fatty acids, polyinsaturated fatty acids may augment tumor development
in some rodent models.
And there may be a protective effect by omega-3 fats.
So I think Cameron was interested in teasing apart those effects of different types of fatty
acids in a mouse model.
And that's an experiment that was set up at the Institute.
Yes.
In 1986, how to live longer in fuel better is published?
Is this something that the L.P.I. staff was part of it all over the whole of the
underlying projects until himself?
Excuse me.
Dorothy Monroe, of course, helped him with that because she was his secretary and she worked
a lot on that book.
And I think he had helped perhaps from Fred Stitt, maybe some other people at the Institute,
but it wasn't an institute-wide effort.
It was done by Linus Pauling.
I think Stella Kerman probably helped him in getting references and things of that nature
too.
As far as I know, Pauling himself produced the draft.
And I believe he shared that probably with some people, including Fred Stitt, for proof
reading and suggestions and so forth.
But I think it was largely his project.
And he directed that the royalties from that book come to the Linus Pauling Institute
of Science and Medicine because he undertook the book as an employee of the Linus Pauling
Institute.
It wasn't something he was doing on his own for financial gain.
He really wanted that money to come to the Institute to support research.
What sort of reaction did you know in response to the book, people that were getting a hold
of the Linus Pauling Institute?
Well, there seemed to be a lot of interest in the book.
The original hardcover was published by WH Freeman.
That wasn't around long.
Then there was a paperback also published by Freeman that was a, what would you call it,
a trade paperback?
It was larger than a regular pocketbook paperback.
And that seemed to sell very well in addition.
And then shortly after the Freeman editions, the mass market paperback rights were auctioned
and Avan was the successful bidder.
And it went, I think it was the best seller for Avan as well and went through many, many,
many printings.
So people really responded to the book.
I mean, I think it was in the New York Times bestseller list for a while.
I'm not sure what the rank was or for how long, but it sold very, very well.
And I don't think that the main impact was financial revenue for the Institute to carry
out research, but more of an awareness of Pauling's ideas in orthomolecular medicine and
the fact that a lot of this research was going on in California at the Linus Pauling Institute.
So it definitely directed attention to the Institute.
But of course, this was before the internet.
So people reading the book and wanting to learn more about the possible impact of vitamin
C and other vitamins and nutritionally essential minerals and so forth on cognitive function
or health, prevention and treatment of cardiovascular disease and cancer and so forth would typically
call or write to the Institute.
And that of course resulted in a huge enterprise.
Because we didn't have very many staff to deal with all these letters that would come in.
And you and Cameron, who had been non-resident fellow in the Institute, I think moved to California
to take up position as medical director maybe around 1984, 1985, somewhere in that mid-1980
period.
And as I said earlier, a lot of his effort was directed at responding to these letters
and phone calls from people with medical problems who wanted to know about the therapeutic
value of micronutrients, especially vitamin C.
And Fred Stitt also helped in that area quite a lot.
Fred had joined the Institute as a volunteer in the early 1980s.
He had known Pauling at Caltech and was actually thanked in Pauling's book on the chemical
bond, Nature of the Chemical Bond.
So he and Pauling had a long relationship.
Fred was retired and had an office at the Institute and Fred became the newsletter editor and
also helped develop some standardized information packets that the Institute could send out to
people who had, because at that point the volume of mail and requests was so large that oftentimes
these things couldn't be handled on a personal basis because it was just overwhelming.
Some of the questions were very peculiar or idiosyncratic and required a little bit of
work to answer a little research to find out what the appropriate response would be.
Some other questions were a little more generic and these information packets were designed
and made to answer those more generic questions.
And Fred was heavily involved in that, putting together these different generic packets that
could go out to people.
So he vetted that mail for the most part?
Fred and you and Karen Mren and Dorothy Monroe, I think Carol Bestelier had been doing this
at Sandhill Road Facility and I don't think that she was still part of the institute
in the 1980s when we moved to the Page Mail Road Facility.
But she had been doing a lot of that in Sandhill Road and actually she identified quite a
few issues.
I think that we're very important for people to think about, especially with respect to
liability, trying not to provide medical advice but being compassionate and being helpful
to people but also not trying to tell them what to do medically because of course we couldn't
do anything like that.
And Carol struggled with a lot of those issues and sort of laid the groundwork for a successful
strategy for answering these kinds of questions.
Interesting, the camera was so closely involved considering his pretty heavy research
to do.
Yeah, well I think he enjoyed it.
He definitely was interested in research but he really was a patient-oriented doctor.
He would have been a terrific doctor to have for personal care because he was very compassionate.
He was a good listener.
And he was not at all afflicted by the kind of arrogant or rushed attitude that you find
in many contemporary physicians just because the insurance reimbursement for physicians
can be, can dictate how medical practice is actually done in this country and doctors
aren't allowed to spend much time with patients.
Cameron was not like that at all.
He was much more old school and really like to listen to people and their problems and
then think about what the appropriate treatment or response would be.
So I think that responding to the public who brought these health questions or concerns
to the institute, I think he enjoyed that.
So in 1987 we mentioned this a little bit already but the vitamin C and AIDS research
starts to make a little bit more of a good describe what that research was.
Yeah, to the best of my recollection, Rex C. Jerawalla had come to the institute from Johns
Hopkins and I believe he knew John Levit at Johns Hopkins as well.
John Levit had joined the institute to direct our molecular carcinogenesis program which
again really didn't have anything to do with orthomolecular medicine.
It was more looking at, as I said molecular carcinogenesis, how genes and certain proteins
can be involved in the development of the cancer phenotype.
He was particularly interested in a mutant beta actin which seemed to be a reliable marker
for many types of human cancer and used protein profiling extensively to do quantitative and
qualitative studies of these gene products that seemed to correlate with cancer.
So Rex C. was a virologist and he set up the laboratory for viral carcinogenesis because
his initial interest was in Cetamigallo viral carcinogenesis and carcinogenesis due to
Herpes virus type 2 infection because it was known at the time that infection with HSV
increased the risk for certain types of gynecologic cancers in women.
I'm not sure that it's related to any increased cancer risk for men but there was an increased
cancer risk for women and I worked with him to some degree in that program.
We were looking at small fragments of Herpes virus type 2 DNA that were sufficient to cause
transformation of rat cells.
So we would grow rat 2 cells which are quasi-normal cells in culture and then transfect them with
these small viral fragments from Herpes virus type 2 and look to see if there were any
observable changes in these rat cells.
We found the PST 2 or 3 C segment was sufficient to cause the rat 2 cells to become over tumor
forming cells when injected into animals.
We also did a lot of protein profiling.
I had expertise in protein profiling at that time and rat C really didn't so that was
what I brought to his project.
And together we also worked on a program that was supported by a philanthropist from Long
Island, New York on Phytoc acid which is found in seeds.
An antioxidant that protects seeds from oxidation because seeds need to store their genetic
program very carefully and be free from oxidative damage while they're waiting to germinate until
the conditions are right for germination.
Phytoc acid plays a very important role in protecting the seed genome.
And this fellow in New York had decided that it may have some anti-cancer effects.
So we were testing the anti-cancer effect of Phytoc acid in Syrian hamster embryos cells
and a number of other tumor cell lines.
I was doing a lot of that work, the cell culture work.
And that generated a few papers including papers that showed that Phytoc acid seemed to
affect cholesterol levels in animals and triglyceride levels in particular and also could inhibit
metal-induced carcinogenesis in animals.
We had a patent awarded for that particular work.
So rexet was pretty well versed in cell culture and virology and carcinogenesis.
And of course in the 1980s being close to San Francisco, everyone was well aware of this
new syndrome that was primarily affecting male homosexuals.
Although there seemed to be, I think at that time, some incidents in hemophiliax2 who
were undergoing blood transfusions, but the etiologic agent responsible for this age-ades
related, Arachia can't remember exactly what the C stands for in that, but it was a syndrome
that preceded overt AIDS.
So people would, of course, it wasn't known that HIV was responsible for AIDS at that time.
So there's a lot of concern about AIDS, Arach and how infectious this disease might be.
And there was a lot of emphasis on things like drug use and sex habits by male homosexuals
that may contribute to immunodeficiency.
So people weren't sure if it was a behavior, etiology, or whether there was some kind of pathogen
involved.
For time, of course, in the 1980s, it became clear from Montennyay's work in France and
also Gallos work in the United States that, aha, there is actually an infectious agent here
of virus that's probably responsible for causing AIDS.
And then cells were available that were infected with this virus, HIV.
We did, we're actually did a lot of work with Steve Herike, who was from Lebanon, N-Line
is Pauling, looking at the effect of vitamin C added to the culture medium in which telemphasites
infected with HIV were grown.
So they wanted to find out whether vitamin C would have any effect on viability of the virus
or replication of the virus.
And they found that it really affected viral replication, very potentally, dramatically
inhibited viral replication.
And that was assayed by amounts of reverse transcriptase and also the formation of syncytia,
which are abnormal cells that are sort of pathologic correlates of telemphasite infection.
So that led to a paper that was published in PNAS with three of them as authors.
I think Pauling was a senior author and Gerowall was perhaps the first author.
And that paper presented the results of these cell culture experiments.
Wasn't any clinical data, but they suggested that this might provide a promising approach
for the treatment of AIDS, namely by that time AZT had been come available to for treatment
of AIDS patients.
AZT is pretty effective at inhibiting the denobo infection of uninfected cells.
So you give AZT to patients and you preserve those uninfected cells from becoming infected
with a virus.
So vitamin C prevents viral replication.
So the idea was that if you give AZT and vitamin C, then you're inhibiting viral replication
and you're protecting, if there is a little bit of viral replication, you're also inhibiting
those new cells from becoming infected.
So the idea was that this might really, if it didn't eradicate the virus and kill the
cells that were infected with a virus, at least it could cause AIDS to become a manageable
disease, perhaps.
So what part of carrying involved?
Well I think Cameron got involved because obviously there were medical issues involved
here and he was Gerowall had a PhD but didn't have a medical degree.
The only other person at the institute, we had a veterinarian, Roger Barth, and Wilcott
had done him, had an MD and Wilcott was doing some work with guinea pigs and neural
atherism at the time.
But he was pretty advanced in age at that time and was not physically very vigorous.
And Cameron was still very vigorous and of course very interesting a lot of these issues.
And I think through conversations with Gerowall and Paul and Cameron just naturally
gravitated to that, especially once it had been demonstrated that vitamin C might have
an important role to play there.
So what was the reaction to this research both in the scientific community and the public?
Well I can't really say that I know what the reaction was in the scientific community.
I think by then maybe many people thought that line is Pauling was going to just publish
great stuff about vitamin C no matter what and that we'd never find anything coming from
the Pauling Institute that had anything to do with a negative effect of vitamin C.
Just so happens that all these experiments were positive.
So vitamin C is not snake oil but it does have a lot of very important and interesting
biochemical and physiological functions in the body and protecting against and treating
different diseases.
So it's not a panacea but it's a really remarkable substance and it's easy to see why line
is Pauling got so interested in it early on.
So I can't say what the professional reaction was.
I know that there were AIDS, there were doctors who treated AIDS patients who were very interested
in our results.
In particular there were several physicians from San Francisco general at the AIDS ward
there who came down to the institute and gave seminars and were in contact with Pauling
and Jerrowall about this.
There was a lot of anecdotal evidence as well from San Francisco and New York and other
major urban centers that had a lot of AIDS cases where some of the patients who were self-medicating
with high dose oral vitamin C seem to be doing a little bit better than their friends who
were not taking high dose vitamin C but there weren't any controlled clinical studies at
that time and I don't think to date there have been any controlled clinical trials on
vitamin C and HIV infection or AIDS.
And of course the RCTs are most persuasive when it comes to adopting new strategies in
medicine.
So absent RCTs I think probably a lot of physicians just ignored it.
It's in the realm of anecdotal evidence.
It really doesn't mean anything.
It's just coincidence.
You have vitamin C might have some value but it's such a pedestrian substance and I'm sure
that there are more promising biotherapies that we get involved in.
We can't completely disregard the political or financial perspectives in that whole debate
either because a lot of physicians who are charged with running clinical trials to evaluate
drugs stand a benefit from financially from the revenue stream should that drug turn
out to be effective.
So a lot of people have tremendous incentive to study drug therapy and there's just not
the same type of incentive with vitamin C.
But public reaction I think varied.
Of course people who were afflicted with AIDS or had friends who were afflicted with
AIDS were quite interested and very appreciative of the institute's work.
Other people who were a little bit who felt for whatever moral reason that AIDS was a behavioral
disease and that we shouldn't really waste money studying these problems that are due
to behavior and if people would just change their behavior it wouldn't have to worry about
this.
So some of those people withdrew support and again as we saw after the negative male clinic
studies on vitamin C and cancer there was a lapse in some financial response to our
direct male solicitation campaign.
But of course that never influenced the work that we undertook.
I mean we undertook work that was fundable either from grants or contracts or from unrestricted
funds that were available to us and be quest for the direct male program but I can't ever
recall any discussion that suggested that any line of work at the institute should be stopped
because it was a negative effect on either the media where we're down, we're nullifying
it or castigating it or donors were shying away because of that work.
So I think that kind of emulates Pauling's courageous attribute and not backing down if
he felt he was right and I think the institute sort of adopted that same strategy.
So that's an important research to do and we're not going to back down just because there's
a lot of revenue.
You mentioned that Cameron Pauling wrote a book about the subject that was going to publish
to you know why that is.
It takes you off it around.
Well my feeling is that they wrote the book without having talked any publisher in advance
to find out first of all if there was any interest in the book.
So I had no publishing contract and secondly I think the book was finished or nearly finished
when Cameron became ill and I think his illness probably led him to pay less attention to
it or be less excited about it.
But I infer that.
I don't know that for sure.
So we talked earlier about the vitamin C and cancer research and the perspective from
the institute, the staff being generally on board behind the, I think it was at the
surface against the same level of vitamin C and age work as well.
I think so.
I mean I never talked to anybody at the institute who expressed any scorn or negative
feelings about that work.
I mean I think everybody, the institute was relatively small and fairly collegial.
I mean there were certain tensions and conflicts that developed over time of course from time
to time as in any organization but I think people were very respectful of one another
when it came to the science like that.
In 1989, Mattias Rat arrived at the institute and I'm wondering if you could share your
first impressions of Rat?
Yeah my first impressions were that he seemed like a very knowledgeable, earnest fellow.
He clearly had developed some exciting ideas with Linus Pauling and it was great to see
Linus Pauling enthused about the Slippoprotein Vitamin C story.
So my initial reactions were quite favorable.
It wasn't until I became aware of some other activities that seemed to be going on outside
the purview of the institute, the Linus Park Heart Foundation and some other things which
seemed to be a little obscure and not really conducted in a transparent way that people
began to question motivation in particular.
Why are these other organizations being set up?
What are they designed to do?
Are they designed to compete with the Linus Plain Institute of Science and Medicine?
This is a complimentary activity and because a lot of that kind of information wasn't
forthcoming when you have kind of that black box, it generates lots of rumors and that's
unfortunate and I think that there was certainly some of that going around at the time.
Although Linus Pauling also had been diagnosed with prostate cancer and Rat was providing
some medical services for Pauling himself and I think everybody appreciated that.
Here was somebody at the institute that Pauling was really interested in from a scientific
standpoint and was also looking out for Pauling's physical welfare.
Well, I think initially everybody was quite enthused about this collaboration.
How do you characterize this personality?
Well I think initially you seem to be very German.
He didn't really seem to have a terribly great sense of humor.
He seemed to be very, I won't say solemn, but very serious minded, polite.
Seemed to treat people fairly.
Did he socialize with the rest of the staff?
There was some socializing.
Throughout the history of the institute, different employees and groups of people would go out
for dinners or lunch or go to bars on weekends or whatever and there was some of that kind
of activity as well.
What was his research program that Pauling was excited about?
Well, Pauling of course had been long interested in vitamin C and cardiovascular disease and
he'd written about this in his book, How to Live Long and Feel Better.
He'd also written about it in articles for executive health which was a tabloid type newsletter.
He'd also written about it for the Linus Piling Institute Science and Medicine newsletter
in the 1970s and 1980s, primarily in the 1980s.
He had a long abiding interest in the possible value of vitamin C and preventing or treating
heart disease.
Rat had some specific interest and data on the potential interaction between vitamin C
and lipoprotein A which is a major constituent of atherosclerotic plaque and also risk factor
for heart disease.
The problem with lipoprotein A is that its levels in the blood don't seem to be amenable
to modification by dietary or even drug strategy.
They're fairly genetically determined and they're very difficult to modulate.
So there's a lot of skepticism as to where the vitamin C could actually affect lipoprotein
A levels in blood.
Rat had apparently some small set of clinical data that apparently showed that vitamin C
might have value in decreasing lipoprotein A levels and I think that was very interesting
to Pauline.
Then together they developed a hypothesis that lipoprotein A may serve as a surrogate for
vitamin C in animals including people that do not synthesize vitamin C.
There are some evidence that lipoprotein A levels in animals and people not synthesizing
vitamin C were high and lipoprotein A levels seem to be low in the blood of those animals
that were synthesizing vitamin C and that led them to think about what is lipoprotein
A doing that vitamin C might otherwise do in the body.
They believe that lipoprotein A might be synthesized by the body to contend with and repair
fishers that develop in the vascular churro due to oxidative damage or shear stress
and other things of that nature.
So it might have a valuable role in repairing lesions but that because it's a very sticky
molecule it could end up developing into atherosclerotic plaque.
From the original hypothesis there were a number of corollaries that developed including
the potential role of lysine in helping to either decrease plaque or keylate and remove
lipoprotein A from the blood.
Pauline published in the Journal of Worth Molecular Medicine in the early 1990s three case reports
of people who had suffered from severe angina, exercised induced angina, who had had very
serious cardiovascular disease bypass and other surgical interventions and still had angina.
And they read Pauline's papers with Raff and decided to try adding lysine to their
regimen.
In some cases these people had already been taking fairly high doses of vitamin C and then
added lysine.
They weren't controlled studies so these were reported as anecdotes and the amount of
lysine and vitamin C was quite variable but it was on the order of 3 to 6 grams per day
of each and they reported fairly rapid relief from angina.
So Pauline speculated that perhaps because the relief was so rapid that lysine might even
bind to lipoprotein A in plaque and help remove it from plaque and that was possibly explaining
why these people were not suffering from angina because the thickness of the plaque was
decreasing.
Well it turns out subsequent research has revealed that vitamin C has very important effects
in vasodilation and sort of improving blood flow in people with atherosclerotic plaque
through its effects on tetrahedribyopterine which is involved in synthesis of nitric oxide
which improves blood flow.
The role of lysine in this process is still obscure and I don't think other than Pauline's
hypothesis I don't think there's been much speculation as to why lysine in particular
might have had this benefit because as I mentioned some of the people that were reported
in these case studies had already been taking very high dose vitamin C without presumably
any benefit yet when they added lysine there seemed to be a fairly dramatic effect.
So that I thought was a very, it's an interesting area and probably a rich area for research
although as far as I know no one's really looked into it.
So those were some of the ideas that Pauline and Wrath were developing in that period that
I think were exciting to everybody and as I came to understand the Linus-Pong Heart Foundation
was specifically set up to raise money to support clinical trials on some of these potential
therapies including proline lysine, vitamin C, niacin and so forth.
We'll talk more about Wrath here in a second.
There's a couple things that happen chronologically that I want to touch on first.
In 1999 there was a rezoning effort in Palo Alto which time the city gave the Institute
three years to move basically.
What was the reaction to that and how did you start applying for that?
Well that was very interesting.
That was about the same time that Emil Zuckakondle and Rick Hicks retired from the Linus-Pong Institute
of Science and Medicine and set up the Institute for Molecular Medical Sciences and we leased
them space within the facility at 440 Page Mill Road to do that.
So that was a very contentious time.
Emil and Rick Hicks left the Institute.
Emil still had strong interest in preserving a research program and yet didn't have a lot
of funding available to him.
So Pauline wanted us to find out whether or not us meaning Stephen Maddox, myself and Z
Kerman to find out whether this was practical and feasible to subtly space in Linus-Pong
Juniors involved in that as well.
To subtly space to IMMS within the building and how the building might be partitioned and
how equipment might be made available to IMMS or how they could share equipment and so
on and so forth.
So that was kind of a contentious time at the Institute but resulted in a subtly
to IMMS because we found a way to make everything work to everyone's satisfaction.
And at about that time I had become executive officer of the Institute and was working
very closely with Linus-Pong Juniors because Linus-Pong senior was undergoing treatment
for cancer and still had problems in structural chemistry and theoretical chemistry and
orthomolecular medicine that he really wanted to devote his time to.
So Linus-Pong junior in the board decided to free his father from administrative responsibilities
and Linus-Pong junior would sort of step in as president or director of the Institute
and I would assist him and initially I was asked by Linus-Pong to assist him and then
later when it became clear that he wasn't really interested in exercising any administrative
responsibility.
Linus-Pong junior stepped in and then I worked very closely with Linus-Pong junior.
And that was my first understanding of the fact that the Institute had this zoning problem
and apparently it had been known for a long time that nobody had really done much about
it.
So Linus-Pong junior and I and the board realized that absent an endowment and a lot of money,
it was really going to be difficult for us to sustain the Institute as a viable biomedical
research organization if we had to move because we had a very favorable leasing arrangement
with our landlords.
The cost of the lease went up only adjusted by CPI, the consumer price index.
So we were paying I think 50 or 55 cents a square foot for 20,000 plus square foot building
in Palo Alto.
And to move we would have been looking at probably 5, 6, 7, 8, 10, $12 a square foot.
So the prospect of moving was not very satisfying because it meant that we would be spending
much more money on just simply renting a facility and not have much money available to
pay staff, recruit or do research.
So that was not an appealing option at all.
But we were suddenly aware that we had three years and we really had to leave because the
master plan in Palo Alto called for changing the mix of commercial and residential properties
because they were becoming very concerned that there weren't enough residential units
for people that worked in Palo Alto.
And it's kind of a, I don't want to go off on a tangent, but I had long discussions with
city planners, city staff, the planning committee for Palo Alto and some of the council members.
And my opinion at the time was, well, that's fine.
You can build condominiums or apartment buildings here, but there's no way you can ensure that
the people who rent or buy these condos or apartment buildings are going to work in Palo
Alto because Palo Alto is a very desirable address.
People might move here and work in Sunnyvale or San Francisco or Hayward or East Bay or
the South Bay and you're just going to increase traffic and it's going to become not necessarily
the outcome that you're striving for with this zoning change.
But be that as it may, we really had to face the inevitable, which was the zoning was going
to change.
So I decided that it was imperative to delay that until we could really come up with
a proper solution for the institute's future.
And taking a page out of Linus Pauling and Eva Helen's book, we set up folding tables
around town outside grocery stores and cafes and had petitions.
And I can't remember the exact wording of the petition, but it was something to the
effect.
Please sign the petition if you'd like to see the institute stay at its location in Palo
Alto if you feel that we're doing good work and so on and so forth.
We had quite a few names signed in those petitions and they were eventually delivered to the
City Council and I made a presentation in the City Council.
Linus Pauling made a presentation in the City Council and eventually we squeak through
with City Council approval to delay that zoning change for a period of time because they
recognized that we were doing valuable work and that we really needed more time to chart
a proper course for the future.
And as one of the Palo Alto City Council members mentioned, she didn't want to read the New
York Times that the City of Palo Alto had kicked the Linus Pauling Institute out of town.
That's interesting.
I had never heard that before.
Yeah, so that was a very successful campaign and I should mention that during these City
Council meeting appearances, you know, I felt well, it's good and fine for me to go
and talk to the City Council and I'd met all of the City Council members individually
and pleaded our case to them and they seemed to be favorably disposed to the institute
although some of them were wavering somewhat.
And I figured that I could make a pretty compelling argument in front of the City Council during
public testimony, but I thought it would really sent you to line as Pauling himself could
appear and I asked him if he would be willing to do that and he said yes, so he went with
me to the City Council meeting and it just so happened that that meeting of the City Council
where they were scheduled to vote on this issue was the first appearance by Geerhart Casper
who was president of Stanford University and there was a tradition where the president
of the university would go and make, I think, on an annual basis of state of the university
addressed to the City Council because Stanford is adjacent to the City of Palo Alto and they
have a lot of mutual interests and mutual conflicts.
So the City is always interested in finding out what Stanford is doing and Stanford is
always interested in finding out what the City is planning so Geerhart Casper was there
to spend 20 minutes or so giving his address to the City Council and as Pauling walked
in and the chambers were full of people who were waiting to give testimony.
Geerhart Casper recognized Pauling and ran over to him and the two of them exchanged pleasantries.
They had never met before and Geerhart Casper who I believe was scheduled before me or
before Pauling on the agenda spent quite a lot of his a lot of time talking about what
a wonderful person Linus Pauling was.
Talked about it Stanford, there are many Nobel Prize winners, there are so many that they
really don't turn heads anymore except for Linus Pauling because Linus Pauling was such
an outstanding scholar and such an outstanding piece activist and scientist that when Pauling
was there heads did turn and I thought it was quite nice of Casper to talk about Pauling
and those glowing terms and Casper is a lawyer so he didn't really have professionally
much exposure to Linus Pauling's work in science but nevertheless he recognized that Pauling
was a really eminent scientist and really wanted to pay tribute to him.
So that kind of cinched the case for us I think and also there was a fellow in the audience
who stood up and introduced himself by name and said that he felt Pauling's work was
very important and the institute's work was very important and really wanted to encourage
the City Council to delay the zoning change and at the end of the meeting when we were
waiting I was with Pauling and the underground garage waiting for the card to come around
and Pauling mentioned to me that he remembered that fellow who gave public testimony he was
a student of his at Caltech and he remembered an incident with him and said that when he
was teaching he had the socratic method of teaching where he would pick out people to
answer questions because the classes were apparently small enough he knew all the students
were new their names so during one of his chemistry lectures he had a question and he
picked this fellow out to answer the question and the fellow proceeded to give an answer
that was really not the right answer but I guess he felt compelled to say something.
So Pauling just nodded and thanked him for the response and at the end of the class Pauling
went up to him and said I'd like to talk with you for a moment and Pauling said you know
it's perfectly okay when you don't know the answer to a question to admit that and
so you don't know the answer actually it's far better than confabulating but I thought
it was it was rather amazing that Pauling remembered that particular incident and this
particular fellow who I'm sure he hadn't thought about or seen for decades.
Backtracking real quick I was interested to do that here that when Zubi Kamalash that
had a lot of things to do with him.
Yeah Zucar Condolin Hicks were good friends and allies and they'd worked very very closely
together and had actually sacrificed a lot for the institute.
A meal had loaned the institute money gone without salary or decreased salary and Rick Hicks
had been also very self-sacrificing trying to help the institute progress over the years.
So I think Rick felt when he meals contract was not renewed that he would leave as well
and so both of them left but Hicks was then voted to join the Board of Trustees of the
Linus Planets to Science and Medicine which I thought was a terrific collegial and important
move for the Board of Trustees to make because Hicks had a lot of insight into fundraising
for the institute and just a lot of knowledge and insight about the institute in general
and I thought it would be very important for him to be associated in a continued way
with the institute.
So I thought that was a very good strategic move to ask Rick to become part of the Board.
An meal of course had his hands full with trying to administer and get his new institute
institute and molecular medical sciences off the ground and an meal had actually wanted
me as well as a number of other people, Jim Fleming and Greg Spicer, Tenebulakos and other
people who were doing more molecular biological work that was not really directly allied with
orthomolecular medicine.
For instance Greg Spicer was doing work in molecular evolution.
Jim Fleming was doing work in molecular bases of aging.
Tenebulakos was working on histones and DNA repair and a lot of those programs didn't
really fit into the orthomolecular scope of the institute and when the institute was reorganized
when Hicks and Zucacondole left the Board decided to refocus the limited resources on orthomolecular
medicine so they wanted to have a much more narrow focus and kind of pair away some of
those programs that were not closely allied with that mission because we just could not
afford to do everything.
And those programs that were being paired away, a meal hoped to collect in this new organization
institute and molecular medical sciences and he did to some extent, did that pretty successfully.
So the versions and the research that was the primary reason for the first of your
nails departure from the institute?
What?
The versions and the research that was was his primary reason for leaving?
Yeah, my understanding was that the Board was very concerned about income and outgo.
So the Board had become increasingly concerned over the late 1980s about the cost of all
the programs at the institute and the variable fundraising success.
The Sessikawa donation, $500,000 a year for 10 years was coming to an end and couldn't
be renewed due to their charter stipulations.
So it was difficult to find money to support some of this work that was not grant funded
and a lot of it was not grant funded.
Where's Eurka had a nice grant from the Department of Energy that was funding his work on
allu sequences and non-conserved and conserved DNA and so forth.
But a meals program that I was involved in looking at metastatic cancer, Greg Spicer's work,
some of the other work was really not funded except through unrestricted funds to the
institute.
The Board decided to ask a meal to shrink the institute so that the expenses would be
more aligned with the actual revenue instead of continuing to grow the institute or allowing
it to continue at what they considered an infeasible size.
And I think a meal didn't want to do that.
So rather than do something that he didn't want to do, I think he resigned.
And with him went where he kicks.
We talked about Cameron's illness in 1991 he died.
I'm wondering if he treated himself at all with some of the techniques that he had to
advocate for and some of the people in court.
You know.
Yeah, that's very interesting.
I had asked Cameron about his own habits with vitamin C supplementation much earlier
before he became sick.
And he said that he was taking a little vitamin C but not taking megas because he thought
that, you know, should he ever get ill, that he wanted to reserve those megas for therapeutic
value.
I think he probably took some vitamin C but as far as I know, he never himself took intravenous
vitamin C.
And again, the differential response to people getting intravenous vitamin C and oral vitamin
C was not well characterized at that time.
It was clear that some of the patients getting IV vitamin C did very well.
But also if you go back and look at the historical record, Cameron's patient pool, some of those
early patients that had complete necrosis of tumors got only oral vitamin C and the
tumor necrosis was a consequence temporally of that high dose oral vitamin C.
So I think Cameron and others believe that oral vitamin C had some anti-cancer effects
as well.
Although much later, of course, these transport molecules for vitamin C were discovered
and this was after Cameron and Pauline had both died.
These discoveries were made.
So now we have a better understanding of the limitations of achieving high concentration
of vitamin C in the blood when you take it only orally.
But in those days, that wasn't well known.
So Cameron may have felt, and I never talked to him about this, but he may have felt that
since some of his patients did quite well apparently on oral vitamin C that maybe intravenous
vitamin C was not important for him.
But he also, at the end of his illness, became less willing to see friends and colleagues.
So there were many occasions when Zellik Herman and Zellik's girlfriend and I would go to
Connie Cameron's house in Redwood City and Ewan was not well enough to see visitors.
So we would sit and chat with Connie Cameron and offer her solace and ask her to pass on
our good wishes to Ewan, but he clearly was not feeling well enough to see visitors.
What was the impact of his death on the Institute?
Well Ewan was such a charismatic and wonderful man that it really had a big impact on people
personally.
I recall his memorial service in Redwood City, Zellik Herman's girlfriend played bagpipes
and it was just an incredibly emotional event.
People were really grieving about Cameron's death.
And of course Pauling was there and Rat was there as well.
Everybody felt terrible about Cameron's death.
In 1992, Mattias Rat was appointed vice president for financial affairs at the Institute.
How did this come about?
That's a good question.
That was 1992, you say?
Yeah.
This was after Cameron's death.
So Cameron was probably Pauling's closest collaborator in Zellik Herman of course as well.
When Rat arrived with these ideas about cardiovascular disease and the proprteen and vitamin C and
he and Pauling started working very closely on this collaboration, I think that sort of
took center stage in Pauling's life.
And although he remained committed to some of the problems that he was working with,
was Zellik Herman, I think his bond with Rat was getting stronger and stronger.
I think Pauling may have unilaterally made that decision to give that appointment to Rat
because he had no reason not to trust him.
Clearly, I think Pauling and Rat perceived perhaps a new focus for research at the Institute
which would be vitamin C and heart disease, especially now that there was this reinvigoration
of this focus on orthomolecular medicine.
So I think that perhaps it seemed logical that Rat would be involved there because they
also had set up the heart foundation and other organizations to try to raise money specifically
for these clinical trials.
So how did things start to unravel with him?
Well I think Rat did a number of things that upset Pauling and caused some consternation
that were kind of, it was kind of a political strategy in the scientific realm which sometimes
can work and sometimes can backfire.
And I remember there was one meeting I believe in Texas.
I can't remember the specific society but it was cardiovascular disease, researchers
and physicians and Rat had Xerox something and put it on every seat in the auditorium
for everybody to read.
Rat was also developing these ideas about big pharma trying to suppress or inhibit work
on orthomolecular medicine.
And I think a lot of people share those opinions to some degree.
And Rat just seemed to be using more of a political strategy to advance the research agenda.
And some of those things were done I think Pauling felt and others felt maybe not in an entirely
appropriate manner.
I remember seeing one press release that Rat had written and Pauling had written all over
it that it was really unwise and uncalled for, had nothing new to announce.
And I think Linus Pauling was starting to worry a little bit about the trust that he placed
in Rat.
So at some point when that fund raising or executive vice president position was, I think
Rath resigned or that position was eliminated.
Stephen Maddox became vice president for finance or fund raising or whatever the particular
title was.
So he sort of succeeded Rick Hicks after an interlude there with Matthias Rath being in that position
for a while.
And Linus Pauling Jr. and I became increasingly concerned about Rath and his activities.
We also became aware of the fact that Rath had not signed the patent agreement and it was
incumbent upon every employee as an obligation of employment to sign a patent agreement.
And the patent agreement was actually quite generous when people joined corporations as
employees they typically surrender all their rights to the company.
Many people can invent and discover wonderful things for companies and not see a dime.
Academic institutions attended a little bit differently and in our organization which
was modeled after an academic institution it was fairly generous to inventors.
So the idea was that if you discover something that may be patentable in the course of your
employment at the institute you can bring that to the institute's administration and
decision we had a patent committee at the time and a decision can be made as to whether
the institute would like to pursue this.
File the you know get the initiate the patent application process or if the institute did
not want to pursue it then they would surrender it to you and you could pursue it at your own
expense and you would have the patent and you could go ahead and license it and if there
was a revenue stream that would be solely yours.
So the patent agreement stipulated should the institute proceed to try to gain a patent
for this invention or discovery that should it be licensed the revenue would be split
between the inventor and the institute and the following percentages and everybody had
signed that.
Linus Pauling had signed that himself and Rath refused to sign it.
I think initially he said he would like to think about it and I think the choice was
given to him well you know you really obligated as an employee to sign this and if you don't
want to sign it then you know perhaps you should think about resigning.
So he asked for some time to think about that and said fine and a day or two later he
said that he wanted to quit and wanted to resign and he did.
What was the source of the litigation that he filed against the institute kind of that
well he resigned and I really had no interest or I mean I had my hands full with trying
to solve a lot of the financial and personnel and research problems at the institute and
think about where the institute should go in the future and Linus planks health and all
these other myriad problems that we were facing.
So I really didn't keep up with what Rath was doing because he resigned from the institute
he was gone.
I didn't really honestly care about what he was doing.
It wasn't until maybe a year or so later that we were served with a lawsuit and he had
set up a company called HealthNow Incorporated and this company was suing Linus Pauling
and the Linus Pauling Institute of Science and Medicine for interference with its business
activities and the gist of the suit was that Rath apparently had been trying to get to
forge business relationships with supplement companies and he was bringing to them these
ideas about vitamin C and heart disease and lysine and so forth presumably to formulate
new products or whatever and according to the suit he had met with discouragement from
some of these company representatives because they didn't know who he was and they would
point to news stories about Linus Pauling, vitamin C and cardiovascular disease or heart
health and in many of those stories Rath's name was omitted.
Not because Pauling failed to give him credit because Pauling I think was very fair and
a gallotarian about that and would always mention Rath when he talked to journalists or media
about these ideas in lipoprotein A and vitamin C and heart disease, atherosclerosis but
because Rath was kind of an unknown quantity and really had no reputation to speak of and
just inferring this media often would drop his name and the focus would be on Linus Pauling
and I think Rath found that very frustrating and discouraging because he perceived that
lack of credit interfering with his ability to make these business relationships with
different supplement companies and so he found an attorney and decided to file suit against
the institute and that led to actually his complaint was dismissed essentially but we
filed a cross complaint because in the course of this litigation he had made a lot of statements
that we felt were injurious to our activities.
At the time we were trying to forge a relationship with Elizabeth Arden and Unilever Corporation
who were interested in developing a line of cosmetic products that would include things
like vitamin C and antioxidants and phytochemicals and they wanted to support some research at
the institute and get involved with the institute in interesting ways and Rath had started
to communicate with these people telling them that we were unreliable business partners
and so on and so forth and that he owned all these rights and so we felt compelled to
sue him to stop interfering with our business relationships and during the course of this
litigation Rath alluded to some agreements that he had executed with Linus Pauling that
he claimed gave him all kinds of rights that we weren't aware of.
So Linus Pauling Jr. and I were bewildered by this and we went to the documents that
Dorothy Monroe pulled out of the file for us and she showed us these agreements that looked
had been written by Rath and signed by Pauling and then in some cases witnessed by a third
party and they had to do with Rath's rights essentially and we were very surprised by
these documents. They didn't seem to be proper and we took them to Linus Pauling and showed
them to him and asked him if he had any memory of these documents or the circumstances
under which he signed them and he looked at them very carefully and was confused about
them and read them and said well that certainly looks like my name I believe that that's my
signature but I don't recall the content of this document at all and now that I read
it I would not have signed it. So we tried to reconstruct why Linus Pauling signed these
documents and we came to the impression and again it's hard to verify this independently
it can't be verified independently but based on statements that Dorothy Monroe and others
made we came to the opinion that Rath had gotten Pauling to sign these documents when he
was executive vice president and may have gone into Pauling's office with a whole sheath
of documents for Pauling to execute and these documents were probably among those papers
and Pauling just signed them without reading them carefully and it turned out in the
consequence of litigation the documents that Pauling had signed giving Rath lots of
rights and ownership were nullified for lack of compensation. So how was all the litigation
involved? Well the litigation was resolved you know typically the court really encourages
you to come to a settlement and there are settlement conferences set up by the court to
get the parties together to hash out a settlement because the court really doesn't want to get
involved in litigation unless it's absolutely necessary so they have retired judges who
mediate these settlement conferences and the retired judge seems to have the strategy
of keeping people in a room until they give up weird out and settle and it's a strategy
I think that works pretty often so we had a number of settlement conferences and eventually
rather than going through a trial Rath sued against us had been dismissed so the only remaining
issue was Rath sued against him across complaint excuse me for libel and judicious info what was
it called interference with our business relationships I can't remember the exact terminology so that
was what was on the table to settle the suit against health now and Rath so we came to a settlement
that we were satisfied with we Rath was supposed to pay us I believe $75,000 we were not to
disparage his activities he would not disparage our activities mutual non disparagement and we
assigned him some patents that he basically had done the work on so we felt you know would be
fine to give them those patents we didn't really expect them to generate any income anyway and that
was the the the gist of the settlement by and large and Rath never paid the $75,000
we mentioned a little bit of course of this interview the role that Linus pointed you played and
essentially inserting himself and dealing with some of the administrative issues that his father
was either disinterested or unable to do because of his advancing age in the clinic health I'm
wondering if you could comment a little bit on sort of last year's arrival at the Institute in the
role that he played in those last few years of his father's life yeah well when the the staff
became aware of the fact that there were problems or financial problems so this was you know
sometime in the very early 1990s and then when Paul had been diagnosed and disclosed his disease
publicly there was quite a lot of anxiety I would say because people really weren't sure what
was going to happen to them to the research programs to the institute and there was just a lot
of unease among the staff and the board I think recognized this and realized that they had to do
something specific and concrete and make some very definite steps and kind of clarify all the
ambiguity and gossip that was going around and kind of put it into the gossip and really lay
things out here's here's where the status is now and here's where we're going to go in the future
and Linus Plain Jr. had been a board member right from the early days at the Institute but I think
he recognized that his father was unwilling or unable to resolve some of these issues in a really
meaningful way so he decided to assert himself more in the role of the board so he decided
or I guess with the board and his father's acknowledgement he became chairman of the board of trustees
and Linus Pauling became director of research I think at that time too so because Pauling was
essentially directing a lot of the research at the Institute anyway so he was director of
research Linus Plain Jr. I believe became chairman of the board and then at some point in there I
moved from becoming executive officer to chief executive officer and because Linus Plain Jr. was
chairman of the board and we have lots of problems and I had very little experience in large scale
administration I'd been administering a relatively small research group with a little bit of fundraising
activity and a little bit of public relations I frequently gave tours to the two people who
visited the Institute and wanted to learn about our science so I had some skills there I guess
or some experience at least and Linus Plain Jr. and I started to work very closely together so I
really I had seen him before but I never had never really worked intensively with him until he
sort of took over management for his father in those early days nearly part of the decade there
and I found him to be very a very reasonable forceful, thoughtful person and I really appreciated
his skill and essentially wisdom in addressing some of these issues that face the Institute he seemed to
have a pretty pretty good way of analyzing some of the problems and together we worked up strategies to
solve some of the issues that we were facing. Was it all in touch with him the Institute of the
Ravon is assumption of this role? I don't think so because I think most people realized that Linus
was not going to be an effective administrator of the Institute at that stage so somebody needed to
take put their hand on the rudder of the ship and start to exercise some direction and I think
people were I mean I can't say what everybody's reaction was about me becoming chief executive
officer because that was an unusual move I didn't have an advanced degree although I had been
co-directing a relative with small research group and there were other people with seniority
that one could have predicted would have been asked to become chief executive officer. I'm not
quite sure why I was asked but I was honestly I was a little flattered and I thought I felt very
stimulated by the challenge of becoming chief executive officer learning more about
what problems the Institute faced and how to solve them because I always considered myself a
bit of a problem solver and here was a whole set of what seemed to be very very serious problem so
I'm not sure I would have taken the job and you know if I'd known when they asked me to become
CEO the magnitude of the problems at the Institute face but I'm glad I did.
What was the biggest challenge in hindsight for you in assuming that role?
Well the biggest problem the biggest immediate problem was funding and it was heartbreaking
for me to lay off people that I had worked with and for for a very very long time.
Absolutely heartbreaking I mean I literally had tears in my eyes when I was telling people that
there was no longer a job for them at the Institute but it was a fact of life and it was sort of my first
first exposure to what it's like to be in charge and make unpopular decisions or decisions that
you don't want to make as a person but you're obligated to make because of the role that you're
playing in an organization so it was it was difficult too.
A couple more questions for today. One event in the Institute that seemed to come at exactly
the right time was the donation to the estate of Carl Spodner.
Yes yes. Can you give any background on this? This is something that seems to provide a bit of a
lifeline for the Institute and most needed it. That's right and as a matter of fact I remarked to a meal
because a meal had already decided at that time that he was leaving. There was kind of a bittersweet
news for a meal because on the one hand you know this was the salvation financial salvation for the
Institute but other decisions that already been made so it came a little too late in some regard.
Spodner to the best of my understanding had been a donor to the Institute for quite a long time,
very small amounts of money and at the time the Institute did not have access to a lot of
research capability to investigate donors based on tax filings or real estate holdings or
zip code or anything like that. These days it's very sophisticated kind of donor research that
philanthropic organizations or foundations can do to find out really who among their constituents
have the ability to make large gifts of one sort or another. Back then we didn't really have that
ability so there was no way of targeting people who were giving small donations to the Institute
cultivation for instance and the other kinds of fundraising strategies that might be developed to
encourage people to give money. So it was a big surprise when we were notified about this estate
that had lots of different aspects to it. I believe there was an office building and a home and
gold coins and money and just a lot of different financial instruments within this estate
and it really did allow us to pay off some of the debts to trustees who had loaned the Institute
money and to kind of get on an even keel a bit and we also within a couple years
became aware of another big request the Phineas State which also helped us establish enough money
so that we could have an endowment that would make the Institute more attractive to a college
university to which we might move and it allowed us to bring 1.5 million dollars at least to
Oregon State University when we moved up here in 1996 to endow the director's position and at
that time there was a match in the state so there was a functional 3 million dollar endowment which
was really a good endowment to attract top caliber scientists for this directorship of the Linus
Long Institute but getting back to the Phineas State when was this the Phineas? The Phineadonation was
sometime in the early 1990s maybe 93 through 94 or 5 I don't really remember the exact date
at that time I was also negotiating contracts with Elizabeth Arden that I expected would produce
a very considerable revenue stream for the Institute for a very conceivably quite a long time
and that to me looked like it might be the financial salvation for the Institute and allow the
Institute to remain as an independent biomedical organization and recruit and attract top caliber
scientists but that was still under negotiation and under development we weren't quite sure
where that was going to go I got a phone call from a woman in New Jersey I believe who said that
she wanted to know if I was aware of... is there going to be Ms. Katherine Phineas? Kathleen Phineas?
I'm not quite sure what her first name was but this woman had been her best friend and was aware
of the last will and testament and told me that she herself had been named as the beneficiary
in the will and was to receive a condominium and the Institute was to receive most of the financial
instruments that were available in the in the estate and then I think there was small donations
elsewhere but it was a fairly large amount of money several million dollars and the woman told me
that Phineas had been deteriorating in recent months and a caregiver had come to live with her
and this caregiver apparently had persuaded Phineas to alter her will and leave everything to him
and the woman who called me thought that this was really unethical and unjust and that this person
exploited a deteriorating woman to his own financial gain and it's her scene that way to me I mean
I didn't know what the facts of the case were but I hired a firm in New Jersey to look into it
and it resulted in a nice settlement for the Institute where we got
a belief several million dollars the caretaker ended up with several hundred thousand dollars
and the woman who brought this to our attention ended up with her condominium
what happened to the Elizabeth Arden relationship?
The Elizabeth Arden relationship was quite promising I was really excited by that because
there was a research element to it they were quite interested in in funding research that would
find out if vitamin C and other micronutrients or phytochemicals could protect skin cells,
caretinocytes from damage by sun exposure because they were starting to develop cosmetic
topical cosmetic products that included these micronutrients and they also had some
preliminary data from their own labs that suggested that topical application of vitamin C and
other substances improve the appearance of the skin and I think from a marketing standpoint they
were excited about getting involved with the Institute because as the director of research told me
their facility was in Trumbull, Connecticut he's the one who really
got in contact with us and asked us if we were interested in working with them in this regard
he said you know he started thinking about vitamin C well who who really knows the most about
vitamin C and as well it's Linus Pong I should contact the Linus Pong Institute and he did
and we decided because the prospect of revenue was so great or the prospect of a lot of
revenue was so great that it wasn't something that we should just take lightly or dismiss
so we spent a lot of time thinking about this and analyzing it and we were some of the trustees
were concerned about the commercial exploitation of the name Linus Pong and they thought you know
perhaps if the product bombs and were associated with it that maybe it will tarnish our reputation
but we worked out an agreement where we had review of all the marketing literature that
Arden and Unilever would produce and they could make certain factual statements about what they
were doing at the institute supporting a research project and so forth and that we were not engaged
in researching development with Arden looking to formulate new products with Arden that wasn't
something that was part of this arrangement or relationship and then we agreed to produce a
joint newsletter that would be translated into many different languages and available at
point of sale in high end departments towards around the world and we did that one newsletter
which featured an interview with Linus Pong Lester Pacta also had an article in that and some
information about the institute because I saw this as a way of expanding our base of constituents
because if we could introduce the institute and its activities to younger people or middle-aged
people that shop at these high end department stores presumably they have high income that they
might get interested in supporting the institute's research and may at some point you know in the
distant future decide to give us bequest as well if they thought the work we were doing was good
so I thought this was a good way to expand the institute's influence get more
public education about what we were doing and generate revenue for the institute and in addition
to that exposure there was also a financial element where we would gain financially from
the sale of some of their products and this looked to be remarkably large magnitude of money
for us really staggering amount of money possibly and everything was great I went to a Humberg
Germany and to New York City and Toronto and participated in press conferences the marketing
materials were all developed the product line was about to be launched and the president of
Elizabeth Arden Bob Phillips at the time left Arden to take a job with Unilever in London which
is the parent company of Elizabeth Arden and they hired a new president from Chicago and this new
president came in and proceeded to turn the company upside down suspended a lot of the research
contracts except for ours suspended a lot of the marketing efforts for new products and things
so unfortunately although everything everybody had expectations for great success because of this
management change at Arden it really interfered with the the rollout of all these products and
marketing strategies and everything else and she was she left the company after a year and it
took them a couple of years after that to fully recover so needless to say our high hopes were
somewhat dashed there because of management issues at Elizabeth Arden and they never followed up on it
in the years afterwards they may have you know I don't really follow the cosmetics industry so I
don't know what they did subsequently but the relationship with the institute eventually came to an
end they continued to provide money you know because we had a contract we had a contract with
Elizabeth Arden and we had a sub license from LC Progyny to use the name Linus Pauling and
so we could use that name in our association our contractual association with Elizabeth Arden
and they were funding a research project as I mentioned that was transferred to
LPI at Oregon State so the funding continued for some time and then eventually that project
funding ran out and then that was the end of the relationship but they also underwrote
our newsletter and they provided I was talking to John McCook who was the vice president for
research at Arden and after Pauling's death I brought up with him the prospect of doing a very
nice commemorative issue of the newsletter that would pay tribute specifically to Linus Pauling
and he thought that was a terrific idea and we didn't have the money to produce anything really
nice ourselves high volume so Arden very graciously underwrote the commemorative booklet that we
produced in lieu of a fall newsletter in 1994 after Linus Pauling died. That's the blue one that we have now.
So the last question for today is August of 94 Linus Pauling dies. How would you characterize
this date at the Institute of Point? Well it was a terrible day I mean it was a day that we knew
was inevitable but you never want to get that news even when you know you should be expecting it.
It was a summer day a beautiful day in Palo Alto. Pauling had been at his ranch in Big Sur
and Celacermin and I and some other people had been down to see him. There was a deposition actually
of Pauling I believe earlier that summer by our attorneys that we went down for
but I didn't have any direct knowledge of his deterioration or health status. I knew that he wasn't
doing really well but I didn't really have any firsthand knowledge of what he was doing there.
So we had worked up in obituary based on information available to us from his biography and from
Paradowski's work and probably from materials that were available to us from special collections.
So we had an obituary ready to go and of course this was as I said before the internet so the
obituary was to be faxed upon notification of Pauling's death. So it had been a typically difficult
day at the institute for me. It was always challenging in those days with litigation and financial
problems and thinking about the future disposition of the institute and so forth. And I remember going
home that day in August and I had a couple of beers before dinner and I got a call from Linus
Pond Jr. Before I had a chance to eat and Linus Pauling Jr. told me that his father had just died
and it really hit me hard because I was kind of surprised at my own emotional reaction because
I really loved Linus Pauling. He was just an amazing person. So immediately I got back in my car.
I went back to the institute and I started faxing these obituraries which I had a stack of obituraries
with media contact numbers. So they went to CBS, New York Times, NBC, excuse me, CNN, whatever
the media contacts we had. I'd sent them out. San Francisco Chronicles, San Jose Mercury,
there were probably 15 or 20 of these to be faxed out. So no sooner had I faxed the third out
and the phones started ringing. And in those days we had an old-fashioned phone system where you
could see a number of little pegs that would light up for an incoming line and I think that
there were as many as six incoming lines. So you could look at a single phone and see six of
these clear pegs and a peg would be lit depending upon what the incoming number was.
And at first, you know, through the third fax there was one of these little pegs that lit up.
So I answered it while I was continuing to fax and it was newsweek or something and they wanted
some pithy quotes about the life of Linus Pauling and it wasn't difficult for me but it really
took some effort to hold myself together to give them cogent statements about Linus Pauling
because I was feeling really sad and I was manically trying to fax all these obituraries out.
And before long, every light was lit and blinking. It was the New York Times, it was CBS,
it was everybody under the sun, one in statements. So I spent the better part of that early evening
there responding to all these phone calls for more information and then the next day of course
everybody at the institute knew that Linus Pauling had died and there was a lot of grief
people were crying and it was a really difficult time for everybody.
In terms of the footing of the institute itself though at that point,
where how do you characterize it? I mean the name sake of the institute is just died and
what is what the outlook for the organization at that point?
Yeah, we had of course in the Board of Trustees meetings which we had very regularly by the way
and then we had reports that went out to the board every month because there were so many
problems and we wanted everything to be done as perfectly as possible. So I would write a report
to the Board of Trustees every month and send it off to all of them by fax and that would cover all
the personnel issues, financial issues. I would have the accountant give us a status of our bank
accounts, investments and so forth so that everybody knew all the time exactly where we were.
And of course we took very seriously the problem of leaving the building in Palo Alto and Linus Pauling
had expressed the desire. I think his first priority was for the institute to remain independent
because I thought I think he felt that we could probably be unsuathed by mainstream medicine
or mainstream science if we retained independence. We could be more
iconic plastic and more of a maverick organization but absent that he completely supported the idea
of integrating into an appropriate university with academic activities that would resonate with
the institute's mission. So who was supportive of that but he died before the discussions with
Oregon State University had really matured. We had lots of people coming to the institute
presenting different options to us ideas about what they would do in the institute, should we
transfer funds to them and the name and so on and so forth. There was a one fellow who was a
relocation specialist who had contacted me who had a lot of contacts with the universities around
the country and thanks to his good graces we initiated discussions with university administrators
in Wisconsin and Boston University in Oklahoma and a lot of different places to find out if there
was any interest in the Linus Pauling Institute. So all those conversations and to be honest with you
so many things were happening in that short period of time I can't really place everything chronologically
Pauling was certainly aware of the desire that the board had to keep the institute going as a
working tribute to his ideas in orthomolecular medicine. And there were different
options being discussed. One for instance was I think this was brought up by one of our trustees
maybe what we should do is just close the institute down, liquidate everything and take that money
and establish a chair in Linus Pauling's name at Caltech or Stanford or someplace like that.
That would be most meaningful to Linus Pauling. So those there were lots of different possibilities
that were that were pretty seriously discussed at those days.
But financially you had a couple pretty big gifts that came and then basically gave you a
bit of water for a little while. That's right and that really improved the probability of
securing the interest of an academic institution too because one problem that we confronted with
lots of universities was that they just didn't have a lot of vacant space. Vacant space doesn't
exist in the university environment. I mean it's subsumed by departments or units right away.
So there wasn't a lot of existing space in any of the universities that we talked with where we
could just walk right in and make ourselves at home. And people have different impressions of the
of the reputation of the institute. So there are always people that believe that Pauling was
flaky with the vitamin C and orthomolecular medicine and there were probably institutions that
shared that attitude as well. So we recognized that any institution who was looking to
gain the Linus Pauling Institute would also be gaining perhaps a little bit of a risk as well.
And the litigation had been covered in the papers so it was a difficult time. There was no question
that it wasn't a perfect organization with a stellar medical scientific record that was coming in
with no stains. There were some problems, image problems perhaps. So we were concerned that
that would be make it very difficult for people to be to warmly receive the institute.
So the money really improved the probability because when you can bring money while suddenly
university administrators can see much more potential if you're bringing some money with you.